hi everyone good morning thank you for
waking up this morning and coming out to
listen to a talk on JavaScript if you
have used a view before can you raise
your hand Oh awesome I didn't realize
there were that many fellow view
developers here so as much as I love you
I know that it's not right for everyone
so I would like you at least by the end
of this talk to just at least consider
using view or trying it out giving it a
shot in your next application
oh and first of all I want to thank NDC
for inviting me here and arranging my
travel this has been a really great
conference so far my name is Gwen I am
from the United States if you couldn't
tell by my accent I am a software
developer and consultant there and
recently I have kind of transitioned
into more of a content creator gone the
whole YouTube route so you can find me
under faraday academy i also publish a
lot of content for free code camp so i
have a three hour long view tutorial so
if you're really excited about view you
can check that out on youtube after this
as well and you can pretty much search
me go ahead a and find me anywhere
online it's not a common name
so what we're gonna cover today we're
gonna talk briefly about some of the
view basics about why people who use
view Jayesh about the design patterns
behind view Jas and then get into
features about the exciting upcoming
view 3.0 release I was hoping it would
be released prior to this talk but at
least we have the alpha version out
which has been out for about three weeks
now
and then we'll go into some of the
future of you what's coming up and then
if you have any questions we can talk
about that at the end so what is view
view calls itself a progressive
framework it kind of coined this term
used in this way at least it is
extremely lightweight and you can use it
all the way from being a tiny library
importing it through a CDN and until a
large-scale framework companies like
gitlab and other large companies
especially in China are using UJS it is
a web framework and it uses a virtual
Dom very similar to react so that's what
it is in a nutshell and I think to
really understand the design of you it's
important to know a little bit about the
history as well so view j/s was started
as a side project by someone named Devin
you back in 2013 he had been a developer
at Google worked heavily with angular
and then decided he wanted a lightweight
framework that would be easy for
prototyping applications so he launched
view in 2014
actually February 3rd so the universe
eree is coming up soon
and then in 2016 you know the community
especially in China had been booming at
that time 2.0 came out in 2016 and then
this year we're going to see 3.0 and you
can see that the whole ecosystem has
evolved over the same
time period with view router state
management view X and view CLI coming
out with version after version over the
last three four years as well so the
important parts of the history are
created in 2014 it became popular in
China first and is now spreading into
the west over the last few years it's
used by the largest Chinese companies
Alibaba and Baidu which is probably part
of the huge growth of our the initial
growth of UJS and it started exploding
in 2017 we saw a lot of growth over the
last two years and were excited about
the growth in 2020 as well so yeah so in
the West people still some people still
to consider view to be a small framework
javascript is the most popular when you
look at any online survey of developers
javascript is by far the most popular
language for professional developers I
think there's a lot of crossover because
people use JavaScript and something else
but it didn't register or review jeaious
didn't register as one of the most
popular frameworks until about 2018
mostly because the respondents for all
these surveys are mostly from the west
so view jeaious really wasn't
popularized in the west and didn't have
a large user base until maybe 2018 and
then you can see the state of jay s
survey that's come out over the last few
years in 2016 most people hadn't heard
of it or hadn't used Vijay s and that's
just grown astronomically to now where
less than like 0.1% of developers having
or JavaScript developers haven't heard
of UJS so why are all these people using
Vijay s the number one reason people
state that they use Vijay s is the low
learning curve is that it's extremely
accessible they can use web technologies
they already know the default syntax for
view is just using HTML with some
templating and JavaScript that's it and
you can use CSS by default
like I said before it's it's a
progressive lightweight framework you
can use as much or as little as you want
of it it stays out of your way it's also
extremely flexible and you can use it to
quickly build a prototype from just one
small page that you want to use to a
large scale application so I'm gonna
compare it with a little a little bit
with other frameworks and show kind of
where the influence behind view came
from so a lot of times when you see a
comparison it's like oh the stars on
github or you know this is the weekly
downloads but you see like the top ten
most popular frameworks all have tens of
thousands of stars and downloads and
what is it the new metric everyone's
comparing is the developer tool installs
to see how many developers are actually
using it I think view had well over a
million in the last year so really you
could look at any of the top ten
frameworks and choose any one by these
metrics so there are a lot more
important things to compare frameworks
based off of so when you look at the
design decisions of a framework there's
a spectrum from a no opinion framework
which we call like a micro framework or
a library and react falls in this area
where it gives you a very specific set
of functions that you can use it just
handles rendering your view from the
JavaScript and then state management
routing just about everything else you
can possibly do in an application is
handled by another library so it's not
opinionated at all about what you use
and on the other end you have the
batteries included frameworks or
frameworks that do a lot of stuff for
you so it's a much higher learning curve
but you know at the same time you're
getting a lot of extra features and
there's always that trade-off so there's
a trade-off between having a beginner
friendly API versus being able to scale
opinionated tooling versus how
broad use case for a lot of users across
the framework there's also flexibility
versus speed
there's primitives like you see in react
you get down on the low level or there's
lots of abstractions on the more
batteries included frameworks but you
can also develop faster or more quickly
and then there's always the trade-off
your users are requesting more features
but that adds more bloat so to all of
these things view kind of falls in the
middle it's not as lightweight as a
library even though it's a very small
package but also it's not as opinionated
it lets you be more flexible than
something like angular or ember
yeah so when you look at the influence
that view Jay s when the VJ s syntax and
design got from angular you can see that
it borrowed the concept of directives
referencing the directive highlighted
the ng bind highlighted in red there
from angular and also got the concept of
two-way data-binding how do you keep
your application state and sync with
your Dom the opinionated ecosystem so
when you look at view Jas there's a
documented like official way to do
almost everything not almost everything
but a lot of things that you would do in
an application like state management
router all those things are officially
controlled and documented by the core
team but you're free to also use
something else if you want and then
using templates so view Jas is
templating system uses that same double
mustache mustache syntax from angular
and then there's also the concept of
dependency injection in view which is
also you'll also have access to it in
view 3 which is coming out and then
there was also a heavy react influence
so the timing of UJS is released in 2014
was after angular and react so view has
a lot of benefit to be able to see these
other frameworks see how they worked and
then be responsive to how they could
create a better framework based off of
that so view did implement a virtual Dom
just like react they used composable
components so basically you break
everything up into the smallest
component that you can and you import
them all into each other to create an
application
it makes logic and view which is
something everyone said was so weird at
first but now everyone seems to love so
you can render your
or your view from your JavaScript and
mix those two elements in the same file
so you have your Dom or your view in the
same file with the logic that acts upon
that view it also remained flexible so
flexibility is one of the best things to
have a vibrant community because you
have a lot of contributors that are
putting their time and effort into
building tools and libraries that go
along with that framework because
there's a lot of solutions that are
needed if if you have a lighter-weight
framework so it kept that flexibility
you like react has and then one of my
favorite things that you inherited is
from jQuery so why is jQuery the number
one most popular library of all time by
far it's still used by a large
percentage of websites if you see it's
cached all over the place it's because
it made hard things simple it's not
because it was crazy computer science
Eeyore did this wild thing it just made
things simple and if you look at the
naming conventions of jQuery it was
exactly what you think it might be if
you couldn't remember because we learned
so many different libraries and tools we
can't remember the entire API of
everything but with jQuery if you tried
to think like oh how do I show this
particular thing on a page it would be
thing dot show if you wanted to hide it
it was thing dot hide it was extremely
easy to use and you know for Ajax calls
and Dom traversal it became the most
popular library because it was way
easier than the other options available
so when you look at view you'll notice
that things are simply named and they
put a lot of time and energy into how
they name things and how humans would
respond and think about the naming of
that and it's really interesting maybe
after this you can listen to the views
on view podcast some of the core team
members are on there and they talked
about specifically why they named things
the way they did and
you so when I first saw you my reaction
was kind of what you know it's this
combination of all these different
frameworks so my friend told me about it
and I looked at it and I was like no
this is weird you know I'm gonna stick
with react at the time so I ended up
picking it up again maybe he's like
eight months later I started to really
use it and then I thought okay so I
think because I hadn't enjoyed my time
using angular 1 so I saw directives and
immediately I was kind of against using
it but then I realized that view was
very kind of nicely designed easy to use
and I was also running so I've been
running a group that teaches people had
a code for about four and a half years
and teaching certain concepts especially
when I was teaching Redux and some other
concepts it was extremely hard to
explain and when I explained view to
people it's much easier for them to
grasp because a lot of them come from an
HTML background and they can use web
technologies that they're used to so in
views design I'm going to talk a little
bit about the design and also about the
design of the ecosystem so views users
are very diverse and if you look at who
view was designed for it didn't come out
of a company of course so it's really
come out of the needs of the different
people using it and what they are using
it for not just what a specific company
used it for and then it was kind of open
sourced as an afterthought or as some
kind of marketing technique so there are
a lot of beginners who get into view
because it's very accessible
you can just import the CDN and then
start using it there's also a large
number of users now which is interesting
they're adding interactivity to legacy
applications so there are there's tons
of jQuery and you know playing
JavaScript all over the web so if you
want to update that what do you do you
know even if you
react which is extremely lightweight you
have the default syntax JSX
and then you need babble and you need
all these other things which is much
heavier you can just import and just use
in your HTML and start transitioning
one-off projects rapid prototyping it's
very good for that medium scale projects
and then large scale projects and with
view 3s update I think it really focused
on how can they help large scale users
better organize their code so I think it
was really they're kind of solidifying
themselves as something not just for
beginners and lightweight applications
but also for enterprise applications so
since view was designed for the
community that uses it I think it's
important to see the demographics of
people who code professionally so when
you look like the Stack Overflow survey
from 2019 there were over eighty
thousand respondents it's by far the
largest developer survey and you can
notice that every year and all these
surveys show that developers and
especially professional coders skew
heavily young and heavily inexperienced
so if you're from a company if you're
doing hiring and you get to choose a
tech tech stack then it's really
important to think who am I going to be
hiring how easy is it going to be to
onboard this person with only one or two
years of experience you know what
technologies am I going to have to teach
them am I going to have to teach them
not just a library but you know 50 other
tools that go along with that in an
ecosystem so it's important to think
about the approach ability and when you
look at view like I said before you can
just import it via a CDN and start using
it so if you see you just refer you just
have a plain Dom element you give it
some kind of marker like an ID and then
you reference that ID in a view instance
pass it an options object and then you
can display the data
inside of the double curly braces
anything inside of there will be parsed
as JavaScript and you can just start
using view J s and linking your state to
your Dom so view also has an excellent
CLI if you used react in 2015 then maybe
you know of the headache that it was I
remember learning web pack and Babel and
setup and all these different things
just to build an application and there
was that mean that went around that you
know this person writing like complex
algorithms on a greased board or a chalk
board and it was just to make a
HelloWorld application so it was so
difficult to set up but fortunately with
view all you have to do is install the
CLI and then there's two things you can
do from there so you can run view UI
which will actually bring up a GUI our
graphical user interface
for you to bootstrap your projects so
you can add a new project and then it
takes you through a wizard so you can
you know choose all the options like the
naming what packages you want to install
what features do are you going to add
testing and state management and routing
and all that other stuff and it'll
install it for you and you can open this
up at any time when you're building your
application just click one button you
don't even have to look through npm you
can just add a package through here and
then there's also the command-line
interface with view create which takes
you through basically the same wizard so
you can add all of your different
features and then it will bootstrap your
whole application the great thing is
that it just works out of the box
more like angular and ember
and then
oh yeah and so when you start from the
CLI it's going to set up similar to
react in other frameworks it sets up
basically a bootstrapped
application where you have these
components and inside your components it
uses regular HTML markup to
differentiate the parts of your
component so it has yeah so it has a
style tag where you can put your CSS or
sass or whatever you want in there and
then it has a script tag where you put
your JavaScript and then I think the
most interesting part is the template
tag so html5 actually released this
template tag because it wanted people to
start composing their HTML files
together and not have these 5,000 line
long HTML files anymore so I don't think
this was heavily used before view j/s I
remember looking at it like 5 or 6 years
ago thinking you know what can we do
with this it would be great there was a
framework that used this and so what's
nice about that is it just uses the same
web standards that already exists and
puts them inside view also template tags
don't render to the Dom as another
element they're just there as a wrapper
yeah and then just like react and other
any other framework really you can
import components into your other
components and then compose them and
render them together make a tree of
components and then like I said before
you uses tool a data binding I think it
is a very intuitive system so you have a
data object in your JavaScript and then
you want to bind it to your HTML you use
a directive v-model and then your DOM
stays in sync with your JavaScript and
then you can do whatever you want with
that value
yeah and then if you want to display it
in the Dom use the double mustache
syntax and you can display that value or
use it in any of your methods another
huge part of you is that it focuses on
reactivity so if you look at regular
JavaScript it's not reactive and you
have to do a lot of work to make it
reactive for example if you want to find
the total of an element so here I'm
adding cat toys and cat treats equals 20
for the first time but what if I add two
more cat toys so now the total should be
26
but since javascript is not reactive by
default the total that if you print out
the total variable again it's still 24
so it doesn't update
fortunately view handles this under the
hood so it gives you reactivity
out-of-the-box so for example if you
look in the upper right hand corner you
can see how this prints out and by the
way all these slides
I guess I didn't put a link there but
I'll put a link there after all these
slides I tweeted them out and they have
jsfiddle links at the bottom so you can
go and play around with the code but
basically if you click on one of these
two buttons it will add one to the
number in the cart and then it will
update that number because if you see
the computed object so anything inside
the computed object any variable that's
inside one of those methods view is
automatically watching if that variable
updates and then it's going to rerun
that method for you and recalculate the
total for you another great thing about
view is that the web heavily depends on
animations now so if you look at any
modern website really things don't just
appear and disappear just like they
don't in real life so view actually
handles animations or gives you a way to
handle animations very easily you can
wrap anything you want to animate inside
a traditional transition component give
it the type of animation that you want
and this includes routing sub routing
you know things that appear and
disappear from the page like modal's and
you basically say like oh you want to
fade it in and out it gives you 6 CSS
classes to handle different parts of the
transition so you can customize it as
much as you want and then just wrap it
in the tag and it gives you the
transition functionality by default and
there are many different built-in
animations and you can also use custom
ones if you want another part of use
composability is how it uses slots so
slots are a way that's been developed to
compose templates together so it's not
just importing you know it's easy to
import JavaScript functions into one
another but what if you want to reuse
this
a templating logic and nest different
parts of the template in different areas
so with slots as you can see the example
I can pass in or I have the template on
top in red and this is for a page and
then I have a header section so I can
put something default in there but you
can see in blue is where I use that
template and then I can pass in using
the V slot directive I can pass in some
markup to put inside the header slot or
inside the footer slot or if I don't
mark anything as being inside a specific
slot it's just going to go into the
default unlabeled slot and I really like
the term slot because naturally when you
think of something named slot you think
oh they have to put something inside of
that so that's another example of use
awesome naming conventions
and so this is actually my favorite part
about view I think is that it handles
complex forms very nicely so any
framework can really you know handle
some user input and selection checkboxes
that kind of stuff but for forms that
have variable number of inputs like this
one that I built
so basically users can create as many
sections as they want and then as many
resources or projects as they want
inside of every section so basically
it's that the way the data is displayed
it's an array of objects nested inside
of another array of objects and how do
you handle that in terms of mapping your
form state to what the user is inputting
if you've used react before I remember
the first time I tried to handle
something like this and unbelievably I
was at a consulting agency and we
handled it doing something like dollar
sign dot something dot something dot
something dot something and it was
extremely inefficient and so then we
started using Redux forms which was
awesome
and worked really well but it was
complicated and view handles this by
default
so what view does is you can use a
simple v4 directive to loop over the
form inputs the number of form inputs
that you have in your Dom the user can
add one remove one it will be added or
removed from the array in state then
it's looped over it in the Dom and then
you can v-model based off of either the
index in an array or the key in an
object and it can just loop over those
and it automatically Maps it to that
index or that dom's and it makes making
crud operations on a variable number of
form inputs very very intuitive to use
so the exciting part let's talk about
view three and to talk about view three
and what's new the major new change in
v3 was a new API that came out called
the composition API so to understand why
it was needed let's look at the API from
you know v1 v2 so the options API and
this is just a screenshot of a component
that I had it was basically all these
different sections you put your data all
your data was together all your methods
were together and everything was was
organized by type all data a lifecycle
stuff all props all methods together all
of your reactive or computed functions
were all together the problem with this
was even though it looks really nice
when you have small components it's so
intuitive it's really nice to get
started and that's you know one of the
features that brings a lot of people
into view but then when you start to
scale your components it's actually it
actually ends up looking like this so
you have your search logic and data and
everything all over the place in the
file and then you have your cart stuff
all over the place and they're kind of
mixed together you
some search methods here and some cart
methods and then you have some cart data
and search data together and it's hard
to navigate so what people you know have
been doing for the last so many years in
the single page application frameworks
is they'll make a new component so you
make a new component you break up the
Dom and also some of the logic you can
put into the other component the problem
is it doesn't always work very well
sometimes you want to keep that logic
together and you also shouldn't need the
extra overhead of having a whole other
component just because you want to
arrange your logic differently there
have been some imperfect solutions in
view in the past and this new functional
composition API is kind of where
everything came to so the composition
API is like I said a functional API
that's a new way to organize your code
by feature it organizes all your logic
for example the data for your store or
the data for your cart will go with the
logic for your cart and the methods and
the computed and the Watchers and the
lifecycle hooks for that one feature
will all be organized together this it's
intuitive because it's also how we
organize our web applications now if you
you know have a folder of components in
your funand application it's it's a
folder for that feature or that part of
the page it's not all your data in one
place and all your view in one place it
doesn't work like that
so you basically create a setup function
inside the same the same options object
that you normally use inside components
you have a new method the set up method
and you can access low-level View api's
from that object or you can import them
from view and use them inside of that
object
so here I'm just importing riff API from
view but basically what it does is turn
this 0 in the blue there into a reactive
object which is saved in the numb items
variable and then I have the add item
method which acts on the num items
variable and I return the function and
the variable from the setup function
anything I returned from the setup
function can be used normally in my
template and in the rest of my component
so this allows me to organize my code by
feature because I can put my data
anywhere I want I don't have to just
have it in one data object I can put my
methods anywhere I want not just some
one methods object etc
so you can look at those examples on
jsfiddle if you want
so of course you don't want to keep all
of this inside one component you that's
why there's basically what they call a
composition functions so you can take
all of these low-level api's and import
them into any JavaScript file from view
make a function like here I have used
cart function and use search function if
if you come from react then you might
recognize this syntax with hooks it's
kind of similar how it works here so
basically you have the used cart and use
search functions and you can use them
inside your setup function you pass any
kind of reactive elements into them or
you can just use those reactive elements
from the file where the function is
created and then you return the bindings
from those functions and they are
explicitly named so you know where
something is coming from in your
component there's no confusion like
there used to be with some former
solutions like mix-ins inside of you and
there's no namespace conflicts unless
you create it yourself so in review of
what composition is there composable
functions that you use inside of a setup
method it gives you logical organization
by feature there is much better code
reuse so if you've used view in the past
you probably know you're writing the
same thing in multiple components at
least when you're creating production
level applications so now you can
abstract away the logic for the feature
and just import it it's easier to
maintain if you're on a team it's easier
to onboard people and typescript users
can rejoice because now everything has
been built from the ground up in
typescript
I know people were kind of frustrated
with that so there was kind of a quasi
working class based syntax that people
were using which has which is not which
is not a part of view 3.0 because this
compositional functional API works very
well with typescript it's just functions
and variables and it works and even if
you're not using typescript you still
get the intellisense the auto completion
all of those features of typescript
because view is now built from the
ground up in typescript which is awesome
and it works really well with tooling
and then there's no extra compute or
component instances which is bad for
performance and it's often only so
unlike this reddit thread that appeared
a few months ago or a few weeks ago that
said oh no everything's deprecated you
know it's kind of like a game of
telephone and it's often only the the
options API is not going away this is
just a new API and you can choose if you
want to use this new API if you want to
use the old API or if you want to use
basically both api's some of the cons to
the new api complexity it's definitely
an more advanced syntax so beginners
won't probably be using it and there's
lots of new API methods this is just
some of them so part of the update and
view was to give you access to all of
these API methods which it does but then
you have to learn all of these new API
methods and with all of these additions
with this new API you know it basically
adds more code more I don't want to call
it bloat but it makes it a bigger
package for view so what view did
is it says we're gonna remove any unused
API methods for option for the options
API or composition API so if you aren't
using a feature in view basically your
bundle size is going to be smaller
because it's not going to be included in
your final bundle so the final bundle as
promised last year will be about 10
kilobytes gzipped plus any additional
features and libraries that you use
which is very awesome and then in the
view 3.0 update they said you have
access to all of the low-level api x'
you have custom rendering if you have
used react you know that react native
can render to any platform and now you
have access to that inside of UJS you
can access the rendering functions so if
you use the components with the template
by default you can just use it I guess
you can just use the DOM and everything
by default or you can drop down to the
lower level and because it gets compiled
into a render function for the virtual
DOM and you can access that now and you
can also access the reactivity system
and manually say hey I want this element
or this piece of data to be reactive and
you can set it as reactive yourself
instead of just letting view kind of
handle all the magic under the hood for
you and then there's also dependency
injection there's a new API for that in
view 3 and much more so yeah those are
examples of the reactivity that you can
just import from view into your
functions or components speed is another
big upgrade in view 3 which is not
surprising because every time a
framework comes out with a new braking
version it's always faster they always
say it's
so there's actually a new change
detection system built into view
so with Dom updates basically with the
virtual Dom it looks through the whole
virtual Dom in the components that
changed and figures out what changed
well now it's modified it to update or
to not look through as much of the
component because it's smarter and it
knows which of the part of the component
might have changed it was basically a
whole virtual Dom rewrite more compiled
time optimizations it's about six times
faster now these are the metrics that
the view team and Evan you came out with
so it'll be interesting when view 3 is
actually released when people test it
which parts are you know six times
faster which parts are two times faster
etc and I'm not really the one to talk
to about all the low level optimizations
but Evan you gave a great talk on all
the optimizations that happened in v3
and you can look at that there and then
the ecosystem for view so if you look at
one of the design decisions of the view
framework that I think was wonderful is
that there are a lot of tools that are
managed by the core team so they're very
well documented there's an official way
to use them and to include them in your
application and they're included and
configurable in the CLI because they're
maintained and they have standards
arranged by the core team so one of them
is state management view X there's
routing which is view router and then
dev tools view dev tools which is just
amazing because it puts view ax dev
tools with traversing your component
looking at component state with
application events just everything is
together in one dev tools interface
there's the view CLI test
which works very well with just and
other testing frameworks
internationalization and then many other
reposes they have like a hundred and six
repos under the court team some of them
are examples and many of them are tools
like these so one big reason you know
back in 2016 or 2017 2018 people were
saying oh don't use view for anything
major because there's not enough
community support and you still see that
in comparisons of like reactive you to
angular its says that oh there's not as
much community support in VJ s and that
was true a few years ago most of the
community support was in China which is
by far views largest user base but now
that's no longer true and you see that
we have or sorry view jeaious has
comparable tools to all the other major
frameworks in server-side rendering very
confusingly there's nuts next and nest
and the because people want to if you
don't know what server-side rendering is
it's basically for optimization seo and
better user experience so there's a
comparable tool next
there's grid some Gadsby and I think
Scully I've never used it but I just
looked it up for angular which is for
the stack which is a static site
generator if you use grid sum and gatsby
i've used both and they're extremely
similar a lot of these tools are almost
identical just ported from one framework
to another accessibility I think it's
the best in view I haven't found another
alternative to view tencel's because I
don't have all of these area and all of
the other accessibility optimizations
memorized so I feel like I have to look
them up anytime I need to use them but
with the utensils I can just wrap a
modal or whatever other component I want
inside of utensils and it gives me all
these accessibility features by default
yeah and then there are so many UI
component libraries you can't even count
the UI component libraries that exist
for every different framework and then
native mobile so very excitingly native
script view came out in 1.0 a year ago
and it's I've used it it's basically
it's a it's a really good tool to make
native feeling mobile apps basically it
works similarly to react native except
native script has 100 100% on native
hardware API coverage by default which
is the same if you use native script
JavaScript or native script angular or
any of those and then there's also weeks
which is used by Alibaba which is a huge
company in China but I haven't used it
so I think I would be remiss if I didn't
quickly talk about the view
documentation
it's full of code samples it's very easy
to read it's made for humans not all
documentation is it has advanced use
cases too there's an excellent cookbook
with examples of how you should use what
explanations of how things work on a
deeper level it's basically what every
piece of documentation kind of aspires
to be in the view Docs so even if you're
not going to use view I think you should
definitely check out the view
documentation oh did I I went all the
way back ok so what's coming out in the
future so view 3.0 is coming out in the
next few months they said the end of q1
I believe so we already have view alpha
so if you want to use in almost ready
API you can go ahead and try it out you
can also try the a the composition API
they made a library for you to use it in
view 2.0 if you want to try it right now
of course all the core libraries are
going to come out at the same
time to match the new view 3.0 release
and the view niversary will be on
February 3rd so if you follow everyone
on Twitter in the view space then it's a
big to-do so if you want to learn more
about view you can check out my 3-hour
tutorial where I get is just basically
coding for three hours in view I'm
coming out with another one as soon as
they release the official version of you
3 if you want to know more about the
design of the framework look I've been
used talks on YouTube or as blog posts
Sara Dresner gives a lot of she's part
of the VJ escort team she is probably
the best view teacher and talks a lot
about animations and SVG's accessibility
there's if you want to see examples of
how view Jas is used in the real world
they have a great cookbook the 4 view
courses view school run by the core team
and then there's also views official
framework comparison so it actually
gives you a big document with comparing
all the different framework so if you
want to see why view might be better or
different than another framework you can
look at that and it especially compares
react because those are the two that are
kind of pitted against each other most
frequently and then there is an
excellent view podcast called views on
view and they have so many episodes
about the view community and tooling and
everything and they do a really good job
on that podcast so yeah so thank you for
coming and we have about 10 minutes so
if you want to ask any questions
yeah I use them and Visual Studio code
so it the support I'd say it's very good
it's the same as any other JavaScript
framework you get syntax highlighting
they have good view snippets there's
tooling and stuff I haven't used the
developer tools there because I use the
view dev tools in the browser
all right so thank you for coming if you
want to talk to me after I could talk
all day about view and JavaScript and
such so yeah thanks for coming